hi becca
um no becca i really was emotionally
struck by why you are doing this today
and would you please share that with
everyone yeah so i mean you know during
my childhood i think
myself as well as many other young girls
you know went to their mom and you know
asked like can i get my ears pierced and
at the time when i asked i was like
maybe a little too young she was like
let's like revisit this um like in a
couple years or something and um
unfortunately before that second
conversation was able to happen she
actually passed away um and it's been
about 10 years since she did and i've
been thinking about
getting you know uh
my ears pierced since then a lot lately
and she left behind a lot of beautiful
jewelry and some of that being earrings
and i would just like love to be able
now to wear some of her stuff um
yeah so i think it's time right
i'm so honored
to be a part of this moment for you it's
very special for me too yeah thank you
thank you for letting me be here to
witness this maria what kind of piercing
do you recommend for becca well we're
going to do her first lobes so
traditional placement first lobe so she
can wear a lot of her mom's jewelry
which was intended for that location and
it's going to be beautiful all right
let's do this all right
thank you for for letting us do this
with you can you hold my hand drill oh
yeah that's important the handhold is
very important
i would be honored so we prepped you and
cleaned you before but i just did a
quick little touch-up now for cleaning
okay
and i'm going to put a little clamp so
it aligns that front and back dot that
we did backstage
so i'm just going to have you take a
deep breath in
and just exhale so take a breath in babe
and ah it's gonna look good yeah
that's the feeling
so i'm just gonna insert the jewelry
yeah the hard part is totally over that
didn't even hurt at all that's so crazy
it's all in the marking
[Laughter]
just screwing on the start all right
yeah your piece is it i'm just
what's up how do you feel i'm good
you're good
yeah the idea of all of this really
spoke to me
is there anything else other than
earrings that makes you think about your
mom
weirdly tomatoes she would like she
would slice them and then you know at
the end like the bottom of the tomato oh
we're switching perfect
this hand was getting sweaty um i know
we got clams
but she would slice the avocado and then
at the end where there's like not really
any seeds or anything she would just
like put salt on it and we would like
eat them together like the ends of the
tomato so i think about that
when i slice tomatoes sometimes
[Laughter]
was she funny was she serious like very
funny she had like a really large like
laugh
um so
yeah and sometimes when i laugh my
family says that they can like see her
like her face i guess i look like her
which is good yeah so
so ready again okay take a breath in
excellent
number two now it's just slipping that
jewelry again oh my goodness that's the
hard part's over
are we done
oh my gosh it's so pretty very good ben
and of course i would love to show you
the final product and a mirror release
then like mirror reveal
oh perfect wonderful dun dun dun
take a gander
wow
wow
they're they're really beautiful right
[Applause]
what an amazing opportunity and also
thank you so much for for keeping me in
such good hands um and i'm just excited
to one day be able to wear
mom's stuff yeah thank you
thank you about eight weeks you can
change it thank you so much thank you oh
my pleasure thank you guys
and we honor your mom today yes we do oh
she's here yeah she is here
so proud and so loving and thank you so
much for letting us be in that energy
bubble of you and her and honor her
oh my goodness thank you so much this
was so special and i was so looking
forward to it and it's even more
meaningful than it was in my mind um
maria
um i know we've got to end the show here
um but i was wondering what do you think
do you think like
i
i think we should match together you
want to make it permanent yes maria will
you come up to our digital space i'd be
honored to i would be your little
subject and i could get a piercing yeah
okay
[Music]